في مشهد غريب شركه طيران امريكيه طلبته من
مسافره سمينه الصعود على ميزان الامتعه
للتاكد من وزنها تخيلوا الحادث طبعا اثارا
للانتقادات خاصه انهم قاموا بذلك لاتخاذ
قرار بالسماح لها بالصعود الى الطائره او
حتى منعها من ذلك اذا كان وزنها عالي
الشركه بررت بانها مضطره لمعرفه اوزان
الركاب لان الطائره كانت صغيره وهذا
الاجراء كان لاسباب تتعلق بالسلامه طبعا
المتابعون عبروا على وسائل التواصل عن
انزعاجهم بالنيابه عن السيده بينما اعتبر
عدد قليل بان السلامه
اولويه في مثل هذه المواقف
تخيلوا طبعا تخيل بانه نسبه البدانه في
الولايات المتحده
اكثر من 36% حتى مرات في بعض السنين تصل
الى 39% يعني تخيل 40% تقريبا من الشعب
الامريكي بديل اذا طبقوا هذا القانون حتى
على الطيارات الكبيره يعني نص الشعب يسافر
يعني تبرير من قبل الشركه ولكن هل يحق لها
رفع الدعوه عليها وبالتالي مطالبه بتعويض
يحق له على اي موضوع
ترفع دعوه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج وال الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات